I would like to introduce Robbie Robbie
is a tech lead on the Google cloud
platform and one of the founding members
of the team he built the first 10 server
back-end of cloud machine learning
engine service and currently he's
focused on ML prediction and related
services likes to work in other areas of
machine learning and cloud platform
before his time at Google
he studied statistical natural language
processing culminating in a dissertation
in the area of machine learning known as
active learning Robbie in his outside
work time you know spent likes to spend
time with his kids he has five lovely
kids and he's very passionate about that
I known Robbie for the last two and a
half years and you couldn't have been in
in more better hands than then Robbie so
Robbie please take it away
all right thanks for that introduction
to need my name is Robbie Hart L like he
said and I'm really excited to be here
just by way I know you're gonna fill out
we keep saying hey we want feedback bah
blah blah blah a couple questions along
that line just informally how many here
would consider their role to be a data
scientist their primary role with their
company that's a good number but I might
not even be half are just over half what
about data engineer you consider that
some of the same hands went up if you
told me before I would have chosen the
other one right you got some data
engineers what about just like software
engineer that's a that's a good a lot of
people so those that are software
engineers are you here because like
machine learning is maybe a hobby or
something that you're looking to get
into so you can go down that path in
your career is that why you're here
anyone here for other reasons just
because of pizza someone here for the
pizza that's why I that's why I came
they said you can't have free pizza but
you got to give a talk I said worth it
so here we are you're doing a start-up
and so you're here to figure out what
what's on offer for that right yes very
cool
well speaking of that let's set
expectations so as was mentioned I'm one
of the leads on the cloudy I platform
team right so our job is to provide a
platform for you guys to do machine
learning so if you came here thinking
that I'm gonna show you how to train
really fancy models to get the highest
accuracy and here's the tricks you do in
SK learn and here's the hyper parameters
you tweak in XG boost you're probably
not at the right talk I hope you'll stay
anyways I hope you'll stay anyways but
what I'm here to show you is what the
cloudy I plan are you seem like all my
emails come up and stuff what what the
cloudy I platform can do for you folks
in your roles either as a hobbyist
trying to learn as a data scientist
trying to get your job done as a startup
I think cloud off has a lot of benefits
for startups actually how many here are
at would consider yourself to be working
for a startup I'll raise my hand you're
like what Google's not a startup but you
know cloudy high platform this is this
is a relatively new area I know that
they have existed Google actually I
worked for an internship at Google for
what was known as the prediction API and
we recently turned that down but that
was one of the first like public cloud
machine learning offerings and I was
actually sad to see it turned down not
just because I worked on it I think it
was actually ahead of its time quite a
bit and it's still probably ahead of its
time we still probably have a few more
years to go until we can really realize
the promise of here's the CSV here's
your trained model go for it right but
anyways thank you for entertaining that
and thank you for me for setting this up
I'd like to think that I was capable of
doing that myself as I begin here
special thanks to people that helped me
with the slides and the demos that are
here I couldn't have put it together
without the following people Noah Negri
young-hee Kwan Bhupesh Chandra Kathy
Tang who's in the audience right now and
the rest of the cloud platform team so I
really appreciate all the help they gave
me with the demos and stuff and then of
course special thanks to those that
organized this meeting and special
thanks to all of you that are attending
back to the topic of providing feedback
you know I think we need mentioned that
cloudy I platform started about three
ago so we do have some experience with
working with users with getting their
needs and requirements and trying to
understand those that said we believe
that we're at the very beginning stages
and that there's so much more that we
can and should do and in fact we believe
that we're in a hypothesis testing phase
right and what we would like to do is
we've made certain assumptions and as
you go as we go through this talk with
you if you notice some assumption that
we made that are wrong I'd like you to
come up to one of us afterwards and say
hey what about this did you think of
this way or hey you know what our
requirements are actually a little bit
different have you thought about
providing this and we'd really like to
understand those things because if we
build a platform that you can't use I've
just wasted the last three years of my
life and I'd like to think that I was
trying to do something useful and even
if I failed the last three years I'd
like to continue to on this path of
building something that you guys can use
so the topic of the talk as has been
mentioned is well I I kind of changed
the topic slightly but its production
scikit-learn and XG boost specifically
in the cloud we'll talk just briefly
about off the cloud use cases but you
guys are most of you here about half a
you said your data scientists some of
your hobbyists or did ml in grad school
so you're very familiar with this is my
mic still on I feel like it went off
we're so good ok you guys could probably
preach to me about this this is my view
I won't spend a lot of time on it
because I believe you're all familiar
with it the model development cycle is
more or less like this
you have a problem to solve you collect
data that will help you solve that
problem you almost always have to clean
the data then you decide what model you
want to use if it's an image
classification or some sort of
perception problem audio tech maybe some
text you might use a neural network but
if it's a click-through rate prediction
you might use logistic regression if
it's structured learning maybe you'll
use gradient boosted decision trees
something to that effect those of you
that have been in the field long enough
kind of already know this type of
problem this model works well with this
type of problem then you need to go
through and take this raw data that
you've cleaned and analyzed and
collected and you need to do some
feature engineering especially if it's
logistic regression or some sort of
linear model you're going to need
possibly quantization one-hot encoding
you're going to need to do
feature crosses all sorts of things logs
of certain types of features all things
all those types of things right and once
you've done that you can now take your
data set and you can train a model and
most models have hyper parameters and
your goal is not to get a model it's to
get the best possible model given the
model selection and the feature set
so you'll train it you'll do some hyper
parameter tuning and at the end of the
day you have a model and you'll take
that model and you'll analyze the
results hey what's this model doing well
what we're where does it succeed where
does it fail and what can I do to get a
better model out of it and depending on
what the errors are that you say you may
decide ah I didn't have enough data or
my data wasn't clean enough or my
features what I need to add more
features or different features or maybe
I need a new model a different model
class altogether anyways you go through
this feature engineering cycle or model
development cycle and then what you end
up with the model right you have a model
laying on your disk now what so training
a model is simply a means to an end it's
not an end in itself we train models
because we want to do something
interesting the problem is let me see
how many of you can relate to this tweet
the story of enterprise machine learning
it took me three weeks to develop the
model that's not too bad that's probably
about right
she's probably skipping how long it took
to get the data ready but will spotter
that one it's been over 11 months and
it's still not deployed how many of you
guys can relate to this maybe instead of
11 months it's six months maybe it's 20
months but at any rate getting a getting
okay ignoring the data part because we
all know that that's hard very hard
often times but getting the model into
production actually takes often much
longer than training the model and how
many of you think that the fun part is
getting a model into production my guess
is that the reason you're here is
because the fun part is making the model
alright so what if you could take this
is a screen shot and it's very hard to
see of a jupiter notebook what if you
could take your code that you ran to
train the model and click a button and
you're serving your model in production
well I'm here to tell you obviously that
you can and yes I'm running a jupiter
notebook on a pixel book
so that's a plug for those that want to
run Chromebooks here what I'm going to
show you here is the running example
that I'm going to use is to train a
click-through model this is Aria
click-through rate prediction model and
I'm going to use XG boost as the
underlying learner and I'm going to use
some SK learn pipelines again if you
came to see some secret sauce on how to
do this you're gonna be sorely sorely
disappointed because you guys are going
to come back and say why don't you do
this why don't you do that why don't you
do this and in fact I hope you will
because these examples are going to be
in github go ahead and augment them to
your heart's desire and will accept
reasonable submissions in that sense the
training data that we're using is the
curtail sample right that's I think it's
11 gigabytes and it's seven days worth
of click-through data that's publicly
available it was used in a cackle
challenge so if you look at the code
here we're just doing very standard
stuff I tried to keep the example overly
simple for the sake of illustration we
parse a few arguments and just because
they'll show up again I don't want to
spend too much time here base directory
is just sort of so you know where the
logs are and so you know where to export
the model and that type of thing and
then the event date is what I'm going to
do is give it a date I'm going to look
back for seven days use the past seven
days to train them a new model and then
go from there okay so this here is like
cheating I guess max samples of 7,000
recall that I'm on a pixel book I'm not
going to be able to train on seven days
worth of data and I'm gonna emphasize
that point on purpose a little bit later
this little block Beautif beautiful
block of code is just reading in the
data and you you're like why aren't you
using pandas I won't get into those
details but there is a reason it's for
the to get the right data format so we
can use a dict vectorizer here's the XG
boost regressor i'm training a extra
boost model obviously for binary it's
kind of like logistic regression as
opposed and then we create an SK learn
pipeline where we have a dictionary
vectorizer which will turn the
categorical features do the one hot
encoding for us I call pipeline dot fit
we cross our fingers that it works and
we won't necessarily
wait for it to finish but it won't take
very long because I used so little data
and all that stuff it says it's done so
with essentially one line of code you
save the model out I'm sure you guys are
all familiar without a pickle a model
and then this command here GS util is
just it's just a file copy command that
you use to go to the cloud because if
you try to use CP it obviously won't
know how to get it to the cloud so we
saved the model we copied it to the
cloud now we need to actually deploy the
model to us as a service on the cloud
what we're going to do is with these
commands that these two commands here is
that's going to create a REST API for
you that you can then send prediction
requests to and it does all the load
balancing it does all the auto scaling
it does has the web server
authentication authorization prediction
etc we'll talk more about that although
I might condense that part of the slides
anyways in a few minutes so this first
line here we have a notion in the
current service called a model which is
essentially a collection of versions it
allows you to and we'll see how this in
the context of training new models
everyday how it allows you to keep
various versions and switch between them
like I'm serving yesterday's model and I
now need to serve today's model but for
the time being think of it as a
container we create this model if I do
it again I'll get an error because they
have to be unique so I'm not going to
run it now this mess that is curl will
not be there in about a week or two we
just got the command line tool updated
to accept framework as a command and it
wasn't there
so it's essentially it's very similar to
the models create command but it's
versions create so we're saying create a
version of this model and since I bumped
up the version to v4 when I run this
it's actually going to the cloud and you
can imagine because it's doing all the
things I talked about load balancing web
servers blah blah blah blah blah it does
take a little while but ours is actually
very fast it takes about I think the
median time is 90 90 seconds your very
first model may have a little bit more
in a time and be more on the order of
five minutes but takes about a minute
and a half so while we're doing that
let's switch back to the slide deck now
I know we have to do a context switch
for those other engineers you know
software engineers you'll understand
that reference
but the question why has production such
a long pool pulled member that was one
of the pain points that we're addressing
in this talk is that it's hard to get
models to production I wanted to open
that question up to you guys what are
some of the reasons that it takes so
long for models to get into production
in your experience getting the data
well what about once you have the model
though so you got the data you train the
model all you really want is the show
impact right to get better performance
review scores or something like that
don't work validation well that's a good
point actually yeah and I don't talk too
much
I hint at that on one of the slides but
you got you're not going to push
something to production that's a that's
junkie right bring down your your system
any other reasons performance evaluation
absolutely yeah yeah you got to be able
to do a safe rollback very good back
here
yeah how many of you like to do it how
many of you consider your your favorite
thing to do is to manage infrastructure
and if you that's why I have a job here
right doing this exactly I may be the
only one in the room here's a few other
things you guys said some really great
things I didn't even think very hard
about this and these are the ones that
came off the tip of my tongue
her fingers you need to get approvals
you need to do capacity planning some
people I actually had a conversation I
can't remember now it is but they you
know you have to convert your model from
one format to another format and then do
validation on it that type of thing
there's some technical challenges
somebody mentioned that like just
creating a serving system is a very
complex stack you have your load
balancing you have your web server you
have authentication you have
authorization oftentimes you have a
cache you have logging agents you have
monitoring agents they often work
together if you put all these one thing
is to get all those up another thing is
to keep all of them up right because if
any one of those pieces goes down it's
your pager that goes off if you're the
production engineer right and you
probably don't want that to happen and
certainly those of you that are data
scientist even if you're capable of
doing this that's probably the last
thing on earth you'd want to do
otherwise you would be
production engineer and not a data
scientist so here's what Cloud ml engine
prediction offers it's clicked to deploy
it has auto scaling horizontal auto
scaling so as you send up more traffic
it's goes up you send the less traffic
of skills down and it's server lists so
it scales all the way down to zero which
is really fantastic when you're like for
say you're a startup and your traffic
patterns are very sparse at the
beginning phases right you get some
traffic and you're happy
they scales down really low and you're
not so happy or very spiky traffic we
scale up very quickly our servers are
able to serve upscale very world-class
really we give you encryption
authentication authorization logging
monitoring you can organize your models
with labels you can do versioning
rollouts and things of that nature so
let us go back here because it's a
Jupiter notebook you don't get the nice
spinny indicator I don't have a nice
extension to do that but we can go ahead
and just start sending traffic to it so
you can see that this piece of code is
really really boils down to this these
four lines which is essentially one line
that I broke up because lots of lines of
really long line is hard to read or two
lines really you create a connection to
the service and you call execute and you
pass it the data this example it's not
clear from the way I've organized the
Jupiter notebook but it's literally the
same data structure we used for the
local prediction okay that's going to
get translated obviously to JSON because
we've set up a REST API to do that and
you can see if I'm lucky in the previous
round run they were both the same I'll
keep my fingers crossed with the live
demo and I get a warning about
credentials but otherwise we get the
same value what I'm comparing the the
local prediction pipeline not predict
recall that I have a desk in one
pipeline and I'm then calling cloud
prediction and grabbing that out of the
cloud very fast low latency response
times you can see that well it happened
to still be up but if it had scaled down
to zero that request would have taken a
little bit longer to bring up the
servers but it's very fast ok so let's
move on to the next section of the talk
so that's that's prediction
like I said the premise was you have a
model we we combined SK learn features
like pipelines and XG boost as the
underlying model you can use any of the
models that SK learn has to offer any of
the transforms that SK learn has to
offer essentially a click of a button
and we're working on a GUI I think it's
close to being implemented where it's
literally a click of the button you
point to the model and you're off
serving in production at production
scale and you don't where the pager I do
so let's talk a little bit about ml ups
and this asterisk ops if you will is
sort of a buzzword in the industry
you've got DevOps you've got data ops
you've got psyops you got I don't know
what other ops right so of course
there's ml ops because why not right
what do we mean that by that though I
like this diagram if I hadn't a stolen
it from a paper from some folks that
work here at Google I probably would
have chosen a little different boxes but
I think it serves to illustrate the
point very very well about what ml ops
are if I can direct your attention to
that teeny teeny teeny teeny box on this
end of the screen
that's the ml code that's the code that
you guys write as part of your job to
get a model running all the other stuff
is what it takes to serve not just serve
but to train and use ml in a production
scenario sure if you're just fooling
around like for a research paper and you
got to do get a more accurate model than
the last guy that published a paper in
this domain you don't need all this
stuff you can do it in a Jew printer no
but go use colab or cowgirl kernels or
your favorite Jupiter notebook and get
it done if you're gonna do something in
production there's a lot of work that
goes into it you guys are probably very
familiar with the data collection phase
maybe configuration as well obviously
feature extraction in a production
system that has to be running it's like
a service that's running on a continual
basis we have your serving
infrastructure which we already went
into slightly more details about how
complex that can be you've got to have
resources monitoring blah blah blah blah
blah there's a lot that goes into
serving in production so what what is
when you think of the term define the
term ml ups when you define the term
devops
it is bringing software development
process merging software development
processes with software operation right
so you I actually think that that does
not definition does not hold up for ml
ops why because I feel like we should be
taking the ops out of ml so
our jobs in serving production systems
is more like the small black box and
less like everything around it let's let
the infrastructure let's let somebody
else have the job let's let somebody
else carry the pager type of thing and
so that's really our goal so let's just
let me give you an overview of what I
think the step should be for ml ops the
that what most of the ops taken out of
the ml ops the first step is to develop
your model I would hope that that would
be 99 percent of your time you spend the
three weeks to get the best start model
you can out of your data and then you're
ready to use it in production of course
yeah this is the nice GUI that I said
that's not quite there yet but it will
be in a few weeks you click a few
buttons and you deploy it you can go and
I forgot to do this maybe if we have a
chance or we can go back and look at it
but the we have monitoring and logging
for all those models that we just
deployed single click and it's all there
so you're looking at it you're looking
at your Layton sees and you say oh wait
why is my latency so high okay and then
you say oh I get it I didn't have enough
cores or I didn't have enough nodes to
handle the spikes that we had you make a
few tweaks you click a button and you're
often going so yeah maybe there's an
ideally ideally you don't even have to
do this but the reality is we're not
quite there yet so you have to do a
little bit of tweaking but you can even
do it yourself that's how easy it is and
that's how I think ml OP should be done
so why cloud now I don't know I probably
should have asked a question I don't
know how many of you oh let's just do it
how many of you your companies currently
use the cloud for any of their ml you
have a few but not many right and we
find that to be true look I'm not here
to sell you on cloud it might sound like
it and I apologize if that's true
obviously that's what I do for a living
but let's just have an open conversation
here the cloud isn't necessarily for
everybody I have a few conversations
offline with some people but here's
where it does shine and if you fit these
needs you ought to consider it we have
world-class networking and
infrastructure here at Google we really
pride ourselves in that so you can count
on lower latency x' faster startup times
and things than you'd get by rolling
your own solutions elasticity and
scaling those are buzzwords as well but
if you think about it if you purchase a
cluster compute
to put in your own office or your own
data center you have a fixed cost and if
you use more than that you're gonna get
really bad Layton sees when you're
serving because you don't have enough
capacity if you use less than that
you're wasting money on servers that are
sitting idle or worse using power so
that in the cloud you know you're paying
for what you use you scale up you pay
you pay for what you use you scale down
and you're not using any you don't pay
for anything high availability Google
prides itself in this and part of that's
due to the next line which is Google s
Ari's SRA means site reliability
engineer you may have heard of this
Google hires the very best engineers
that know how to run and maintain
production systems and they help design
the system so that there are fewer
outages to begin with and when there are
outages it's their pager that goes off
and they know how to respond and quickly
mitigate any problems that are there and
that's part of the reason why Google
cloud has high availability for its
services is because of these folks here
speed of deployment you saw in 90
seconds we went from a model that I
trained on my laptop to one that was
serving at production grade okay and
then I'll probably see this line
maybe I open emphasize this but I really
believe that the total cost of ownership
and paying for what you use is a real
benefit of the cloud so what if you're
not ready yet there's many reasons why
maybe these use cases doesn't fit your
scenario maybe your company is really
slow at adopting things like cloud or
other technologies or maybe you guys are
just onboarding but you still have a
transition time I'd like to refer you to
cupola which is built by our team the
cloud platform and what it is is it's I
like to call it the Anaconda of ML so
it's a bunch of packages that bring UML
make ml very easy to do on kubernetes so
if you guys are already using kubernetes
or thinking about kubernetes where you
can run it on your laptop with mini cube
where you can run it on your premise on
premise if you have like private cloud
or on-premise erver x' you can run it on
the cloud amazon just released their
kubernetes microsoft azure kubernetes
but obviously i want you to use google's
kubernetes engine and there's the hybrid
case where maybe you do have a data
center and it's act
pasty but when it goes over capacity you
can spill over to the cloud and of
course the cloud ml engine that I'm
focusing on more or less today that we
have I'd like to think of cloud ml
engine is managed coop flow so if you
don't want to manage the stuff yourself
you can pay for the managed service all
right so I focused a lot on prediction
but the ml ups off stuff is a lot more
than just prediction as we saw in the
diagram so now I want to talk a little
bit about non prediction cases and
there's a lot I can say and I can tell
you just as a teaser expect a lot from
Google in in the coming months in a lot
of really cool stuff and that's all I
can say but when might you want to train
in the cloud these may seem obvious but
let's take a second to talk about them
and the cloud you can get really large
machine types how many of you guys have
96 cores sitting under your desk if a
few - I want your machine I can't
remember what we cap out out but I think
it's somewhere like a terabyte of RAM we
have machines that have that much memory
and you know what I found I actually had
an intern do this last summer I said hey
go grab the cartel data set go get as
much RAM as you need get a VM with as
much RAM as you need and train it and
see what happens
it took three hours to train he needed a
lot of RAM hundreds of gigabytes I think
took three hours the training he was
done he didn't have to go figure out how
to do distributed training he just had
to pay for three hours of a server a
fairly reasonable price with that much
RAM shut it down when he was done and he
had a really great model because it was
trained on all that data right number of
cores imagine you're doing hyper
parameter sweep grid search or something
like that and you want to do it in
parallel but you don't want to set up a
spark cluster you don't want to maintain
any of that go get a machine with 96
cores you can run 96 well it depends on
how many cores each jobs running but you
can run you can do a lot of stuff in
parallel with 96 course of course you
don't want to go get a VM and do all
your work on that because you'd be
paying for it the whole time it's
expensive but this is what the crowd the
cloud brings to you I talked about
distributed training it is non-trivial
if anybody's had to setup XG boost to do
a parallel training on SPARC you can do
it there's a some sample code online to
try and do it but it's actually
non-trivial
and we don't yet support XG boost
distributor training but for Chancellor
Flo it's very simple to do distribute
training if you're using TF estimator
you literally have no code to change you
submit it to the cloud and it scales up
to the number of servers you tell it to
scale up to and hopefully one day we can
bring something like that to extra boost
we have a hyper parameter service called
hyper tune which is available for extra
boost and scikit-learn models and it's
it gives you much better results than
doing a grid search or random search and
it's state of the art algorithm so
you'll get best-in-class performance
there and it's all in parallel you know
so you don't have to wait over you don't
have to so I talked to a researcher here
at Google and he says what he does is he
plays around during the day on small
data sets gets things how he likes them
sends off a job at night comes back in
the morning and checks on how well is
modeled this keeps his fingers crossed
that there was no errors halfway through
right anybody relate to that I know
that's what I did during my PhD to
repeatability so what I mean by this is
I think that's the best there's more
examples but the best example this is
with continuous training so we're
talking about training a click-through
rate model where you get new logs and
tons of them every single day and every
single day you're gonna train another
model right and so you're gonna use the
same code and you're gonna use it every
single day or off actually if you a lot
of people train like every hour on it so
they're training very frequently you're
not want you're not going to want to go
to your jupiter notebook and hit a
button at 4:00 p.m. every day to train
another model right this is a repeatable
process it needs to be productionize it
needs to be robust and so the cloud is
really great for this and in fact if
you're taking advantage of those large
machines in those large cores you know
it sends off a jobs it uses all those
things for a short period of time it
shuts it down and you only pay for that
time that you're doing it so let's come
back here to see what that might look
like in the cloud so there is a price to
pay when you're switching from your
local machine to the cloud you do need
to package up your code in a way that
the service can understand and then
multiple ways to do that will be
supporting containers which is becoming
an industry standard way to do it for
now we use Python packages so you just
run
this you just run Python setup type is
test you see the second command then
uploads it to a bucket in the cloud and
I think that's finished and then I'll go
ahead and hit enter and then you can see
right here all I'm doing is saying
submit a training job called
CTR for click-through rate with the
timestamp so it's unique I'm saying that
it's trainer trained this packages is
what we just uploaded the runtime
version tells us which version of now
that's us that's a little I wish that
was more obvious that this was like
scikit-learn whatever version but this
does translate into scikit-learn version
this is cloud ml engines runtime version
one point eight we're gonna do it in US
central it's with this project and a few
command line parameters so just since I
forgot to say this this train dot pi is
that exact code we saw at the beginning
the only thing is like you would
probably take off that Mac sample lines
that I had because my pixel book
couldn't handle and it took me I won't
admit how long it took me to figure out
that's what was crashing on my notebook
because it didn't tell me and you know
you might change the Mac step or the the
number of estimators to be there what
you would have in production this is
your actual production code so you make
a few tweaks you send it off to the
cloud you can see that the job was
queued again we don't have a first-class
integration so we have to go over here
to our list of jobs and let's see that
one you see the spinny thing means it's
still spinning up the machines this is
training our cert our prediction service
actually spins up the machines very very
fast the training takes a little bit
longer I think if it's a single machine
job it's usually around one or two
minutes so we can go to this job here
take a look at the logs
nothing super interesting just to show
you that the there's this integration
here with the logs if I if I'm lucky
enough to get it to come up so you can
see that all the outputs captured in the
logs in case you need to go back and
figure out something that's wrong or
something that's right and you can see
that the job completed successfully okay
so that's how you send off a single job
but the the use case that I was talking
about is really about production izing
this and doing it on a daily basis so
there's a
how many of you are familiar with
airflow by chance a couple of you are
probably the data engineers I think I
mentioned to somebody before we started
I'd hinted a little bit of pipeline here
so what air flow is and there's lots of
orchestration systems but it allows you
to run chain together various processes
that you can then do on a repeated basis
in this case on a daily basis and so you
can see that right here and I'll get
into what this actually means but you
can see that every day for the last two
weeks
this model has that code that we just
submitted to the service to run to
trainer model has run on the previous
seven days worth of data produced a
model and then push that model to
serving so let's go ahead and you can
see that in a graph view here very very
simple dag I did that for the sake of
this demo it just does training and
create version but some you guys have
already pointed out an obvious problem
with that if something went wrong during
training and I pushed it to production
I'd be in a world of hurt could even get
fired for that so what you would
normally do and it's not too much it's
actually not that difficult you can put
another node in the graph that runs
evaluation and another node in the graph
the checks that the that the quality of
that model is better than the previous
or the model that's currently serving
before you push it and then go ahead and
push it to serving but for simplicity
sake I just trained and pushed and you
can look at the code to do that is
actually very very reasonable here again
you have the preliminary which binary do
I use etc this these dag args are just
necessary for air flow to work a little
bit of overhead copy and paste of what I
like to think of it as and then here's
where you say hey with dag in other
words with my pipeline that I'm trying
to define you have this training up
which looks very close to the g-cloud
operation but in Python code it says hey
use this binary for training and then
you have the create version op which
again looks like the g-cloud option for
pushing a version so with I mean I don't
know how many lines the code that is but
the core of this is what 50 20 lines of
code maybe and we've defined this
pipeline that we're able to run in the
cloud on a daily basis that pushes the
models to production let's see if I have
this so you can see here's the model CTR
daily
remember I said models like a container
for versions and here are all the
versions of that model that got pushed
on a daily basis now also in a
production system you'd probably be
garbage collecting these so you didn't
have so many laying around you can see
that this is the default one so if I
send traffic to this model it's gonna
actually go to that version you'd want
to update that on the daily basis at
least after you'd validated it so yeah
any any question I forgot to say this it
was kind of difficult with all the
interruptions we had my preference was
gonna be to have questions in line but
I'm almost at the end of my talk now but
any questions about these pipelines or
the training yeah yep yep yeah so if you
do your print statements your login info
statements if you're a Python programmer
those things show up here and I think it
tells you which ones which those the the
standard air shows up as unfortunately
as orange warning signs but because
there's nothing to be worried about
that's just that's just XG boost telling
us that it's doing work any other
questions so this is really really the
end of my talk just to summarize in a
few points production ization is hard
cloud is easy and you pay for what you
use on the cloud alright and a few
teasers I guess before we move to see if
there's any other questions about the
entirety of the talk but our team is
working on increased focus on reducing
ml ups so we saw probably 10 boxes on
that page and I only I addressed a few
of them like the continuous training
case and the serving case but there's
actually a lot more boxes on there and
you better believe that we're spending
time making this easier and easier as
time goes on increased cost efficiencies
work that's a continuous focus for us
let's read because we're able to
amortize the cost of the infrastructure
across everybody so we're actually able
to get you lower costs and you might on
your own and then we're also working to
allow date
scientists like yourself and even data
engineers as well to share their
reusable work with others we're working
on on ways to do that
[Music]
you